I cannot speak to what types of discounts
will be legal when Joe Biden is president.
So a great time to take advantage of the coupon
code.
Fresh Start, which will save you 70 percent,
an unconscionable amount of money.
Let's hear from some folks in the audience
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash discord,
starting with David from St. Louis, David
from St. Louis.
You're on the air.
What's going on?
Hi.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can tell that you're coming in beautifully.
All right, great.
Thanks for taking my call.
Pleasure.
Yeah.
So I had a couple of questions for you.
So first, I understand that you generally
support the national popular vote and the
interstate compact.
Yes.
Now, before we go any further, make sure to
turn on do not disturb on discord because
we're starting to get the discord boiling
over your voice.
And that's that's a pain.
I'm definitely new to this, so.
Oh, boy, can you hear me?
I can, yes, yeah, I'm not trying to do that.
So I'm just going to mute my odd my sound
while I'm talking.
OK.
OK, beautiful.
All right.
So my question is about the national popular
vote Interstate Compact.
Basically, I understand you support that.
So my question is in terms of rank choice
voting, which I'm I've become more interested
in lately, what are your thoughts on the ballot
criticisms of that?
And also just kind of like personally, who
would you rank in terms of like your top three,
let's say, for the latest presidential election?
My top of people who actually the people who
ran, I would have ranked Joe Biden first.
So I you know, if you're asking about theoretically
people who didn't who didn't run but from
who was on the ballot in November 3rd, I would
have ranked Biden one.
But maybe I'm misunderstanding that because
we've got a bunch of segments about ranked
choice voting and different versions of it.
There are versions of ranked choice voting
in which theoretically the person who wins
is one that did not actually have a plurality
of first choice votes.
And that's something that I think we should
seek to avoid.
But there are some other methods, and I don't
remember now because the expert we interviewed
about it was about a year ago, it may be single
transferable vote that resolves that problem.
But I think that a national popular vote with
some version of single transferable vote would
be very interesting.
I think it's extraordinarily unlikely that
all of these things get changed at once.
And so I think that the the lowest hanging
fruit is individual states like, for example,
Maine changing away from a first past the
post voting system, while at the same time
we push the national popular vote interstate
compact.
But these things would work nicely together.
But they are two different things and they're
likely to be if successes are going to be
achieved, they likely will not be at the same
time.
Yeah, so so that was the one that you just
described before about the the one that I
heard of was from Andrew Yang because I was
following him during the election and he was
describing it the way, like, you could put
your hand up your top person, let's say, based
on policy, that you were most, you know, that
you believed you like most supported and then
maybe put second or third the person you thought
was most likely going to win.
So let's say for me, it would have been like
Andrew Yang and Elizabeth Warren and then
Joe Biden or not necessarily in that order.
But the idea that you could put your top person
first and then if they don't get the enough,
the requisite amount of votes to move forward
with a plurality, let's say, then Joe Biden
gets all those votes, that's exactly the idea.
And it eliminates the spoiler effect, which
which deters a lot of people from voting a
third party in the first place.
So that's one of the main attractions.
David from St. Louis.
I really appreciate the call.
I'm going to let you go.
I know you had a number of other questions,
but we've got a bunch of people waiting.
So we're going to keep we're going to keep
going here.